como exitosa y ejemplar fue calificada
la jornada de ayer por parte de las
autoridades chilenas en la que participó
un 20% del patrón electoral convocado
para estas elecciones de 14.900 mil
personas una participación un poco más
baja de lo que se esperaba
en función de lo que podríamos juzgar
por las largas filas que se veían en
muchos colegios electorales ahora mismo
se vive un momento también histórico
puesto que las urnas van a abrir en una
hora más pero en este momento están
custodiadas bajo la visión de las
fuerzas armadas y también de mucha
población civil que acudió a pasar la
noche algunos con sus mantas sus sacos
de dormir para asegurar la legitimidad
del proceso que estas urnas no iban a
ser alteradas es una situación inédita
como las muchas de las que se viven en
este proceso histórico la participación
se estima en esta jornada para 3
millones de personas aproximadamente las
mismas que votaron ayer pero podría
producirse que muchas personas acudieran
hoy a votar por dos factores uno porque
los chilenos suelen ser bastante de
último minuto como muchas otras
poblaciones
y dos porque también hay muchas personas
que desconfiaban un poco existía esa
susceptibilidad de desconfiar de la
custodia de las urnas por parte de las
fuerzas armadas que es una institución
que junto con carabineros está bastante
desprestigiada en el país veremos a ver
lo que ocurre si se puede alcanzar el 7
los 7 millones y medio de personas que
votaron para el plebiscito un 51 por
ciento de la participación que tuvo
lugar en ese lugar en esta ocasión en
estas elecciones históricas en las que
se eligen se presentan más de 16 mil
cargos y se eligen más de 2700 entre
alcaldes concejales gobernadores que se
elijan por primera vez y por supuesto
los 155 miembros que estarán encargados
de escribir una constitución que será
paritario que contará también con
representantes indígenas por primera vez
en la historia de chile